if there's one thing europe needed
during the economic crisis
it was a clear way to restore confidence
among jittery financial markets
well now the eu has it the european
stability mechanism
a key plank of europe's response to the
crisis and the main pillar of support
for member states in
financial troubles the esm was
inaugurated in 2012
to help prevent sovereign debt tensions
and financial shock waves
like those that have shaken the globe in
recent years it's a
permanent structure that policymakers
believe will help euro area member
states
withstand economic incidents that might
threaten their financial stability
and possibly that of the entire european
union
the esm is a permanent institution has a
firepower
a total landing capacity of 500 billion
euros
so far the esm has only used about 50
billion
for spain and cyprus so 90 or 450
billion euro
is still left the annual meeting on june
20 of the esm's board of governors
its top decision-making body comprised
of euro area finance ministers
coincides with the phasing out of the
temporary european
financial stability facility the board
is also due to approve the esm's annual
report
when a country requests help in time of
need the esm can issue bonds or other
debt instruments onto world financial
markets to raise
capital it can provide loans to members
intervene on primary and secondary debt
markets
or take other action based on a
precautionary program
its actions will require a memorandum of
understanding
negotiated between the country needing
the help and the european commission
the european central bank is also
involved providing support but also
monitoring proceedings to ensure that
the country
is regaining stability the mechanism
which
cooperates closely with the
international monetary fund
is able to react quickly and decisively
and is insulated from the ratings
problems faced by eu member states